cbs news has learned that former
president trump's legal team is planning
to ask a florida judge to appoint an
intermediary to review the government's
documents that were seized by the fbi at
trump's florida state many of those
documents were top secret a federal
judge has given the department of
justice until next week to file a
redacted version of the affidavit that
it used to get approval for the search
of mar-a-lago the document which one
prosecutor described as a road map of
their investigation could then be
released to the public natalie brand is
in our washington newsroom with the
latest and natalie that's what has a lot
of people concerned good morning
good morning dana and while the doj
faces that deadline set by the judge's
order we've also learned two sources
close to former president trump say that
his legal team is thinking through how
to handle security footage that shows
fbi agents executing the search warrant
at mar-a-lago that's in addition to this
potential new motion
nearly two weeks after the fbi removed
classified and top secret documents from
former president donald trump's florida
home cbs news has learned trump's legal
team may soon file a motion that would
seek the appointment of an independent
official to examine the sea's documents
one of the benefits of a special master
if the master agrees with this is we can
stop doj in their tracks when it comes
to inspecting these documents the
development comes as a federal
magistrate judge in florida has
indicated he could potentially unseal
parts of the affidavit behind the search
in what would be an unprecedented move
judge bruce rinehart who also signed off
on the search warrant has given the
justice department until next thursday
to submit proposed redactions attorney
david weinstein previously served in the
u.s attorney's office for the southern
district of florida the meat of the
affidavit they're going through that
with a fine-toothed comb and they have
to go through it not only sentence by
sentence and paragraph by paragraph but
word by word court documents unsealed
this week indicate possible crimes under
investigation could be willful retention
of national defense information
concealment or removal of government
records and obstruction of federal
investigation these are very serious
charges it doesn't matter who you are
what position you occupied when you were
part of the government the department of
justice has described its investigation
as one with national security
implications saying releasing the
affidavit could do irreparable damage
but more than a dozen media
organizations including cbs news argue
the public has a clear and powerful
interest in understanding more of what
prompted the unprecedented search it's
just one of multiple probes involving
the former president former vice
president mike pence has signaled he's
willing to consider testifying before
the january 6 committee if they present
a formal invitation for the committee
i've said we'll give it due
consideration
meanwhile some lawmakers are now calling
on social media companies to address a
rise in violent threats against federal
law enforcement since the search at
mar-a-lago they want to know how the
companies are planning to prevent their
platforms from being used to incite
violence jeff
natalie thank you very much